let's see we have this graph over here
with T is the independent variable on
the on the horizontal axis and D is the
dependent variable on the vertical axis
and then they have a table here looks
like this table corresponds to this
graph when T equals 1 D is for T when T
is equal to 2 D is a T so these points
correspond to points on this line and
then they explain to us you are buying a
gym membership the membership costs $40
per month and the graph and table above
D is the number total number of dollars
that you pay for your gym membership so
that's D right over there and T is the
time in months that you keep the
membership write an equation for the
amount of money D that you pay for your
gym membership if you keep the
membership 40 months and you see that
here if you're one month you pay $40 two
months you pay another four dollars you
pay $80 you see that in the graph right
over here if you have zero months you
pay nothing then one month $40 the next
month another $40 getting you to 80 so
if I were to write this as an equation
well the dependent variable here is the
amount that I pay in dollars so that is
going to depend on the time and how is
it going to depend on the time in months
well I'm going to pay $40 per month
times the number of months so I can
either write it as 40 with a little
asterisk sign which is shift 8 or I
could literally and then I put T there
or I could literally put just a T right
over there and I think that's right
because if I if if my time is 0
according to this table and according to
this graph I pay nothing if there was
some initial membership charge then
maybe we would add that membership
charge and you would pay the monthly fee
after that but here this looks about
right that the dollars paid is equal to
40 40 times the time in month the time
in months is the independent variable
it drives the dependent variable the
number of dollars you pay